[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rick new heisel cbs sports college
football analyst of course
former college coach all right let's
start with ohio state
uh what's going on with the covet test
here
well as all great reporters do now that
i'm on your side of the tracks and the
media
i'm just probing i'm just uh you know
trying to get
inside information a friend of mine out
in california who's very close to the
program gave me that information didn't
give me a name
so i was asking rick pizo yesterday on
siriusxm uh who it was he did not uh
give me any names either but did not say
that it was a false
rumor so we'll wait and see the bigger
question not so much for the
northwestern game
is will it be a big ten rule that is a
20
21 day quarantine which would of course
then keep him out of a new year's day
game should this have happened over the
course of this week so
that that's uh what we're trying to
divulge
we're not armchair quarterbacks we're
armchair ophthalmologists this weekend
with the eye test here
so oh my can ohio state
win but hurt their chances by barely
beating northwestern
like is there a scenario where ohio
state could win and not stay in the
final four
i don't believe so i think uh they're
the darlings uh
they have i mean they were they were
number two in the country without even
having played right even when
before the games were done this when the
announcement came back that the big ten
was going to be uh
in the fray starting in late october
ohio state started getting into the
rankings
without even having played a game so i
think the buckeyes
are a lock uh short of losing to
northwestern
if you were on the committee and i just
said to you privately
what is your philosophy could you look
at this and go
look we want the four best matchups we
want
tv ratings we want you know powerhouses
in here
and whatever way it is however we do
this this is what we want to do like
do could that be the philosophy of the
playoff committee
without them ever telling us that from
outside looking in it looks as if it is
yeah given the brand recognition now
having known a lot of people on that
committee uh
in you know not questioning their
integrity in any way shape or form
uh the problem with the committee's
directive is they are asked to give us
the four best teams
and all of us growing up realize that we
want the four most deserving teams
meaning that you've wanted on the field
of play
you can't ignore that you know let's
let's just lose
use louisiana they went to iowa state
and beat them by 17 points and
here they are 12 spots behind with
one loss while iowa state is up there
with two losses now we can all say that
on another day and given the
improvement that we've seen with iowa
state we would probably pick iowa state
to beat
louisiana if they played again but the
bottom line is
we saw the game and the game told us
another thing so
ultimately we've got a group of five
that's being locked out of this college
football playoff
and we've got some brands you know a lot
the new york yankees
that the television people are just in
love with and want to see
continue to play i've been railing on
this the last couple of days and i'm
sure this audience is tired of hearing
me talk about this so
what is equitable for for the schools
like cincinnati will never play in the
final four
coastal carolina byu you can run down
these schools
they're they're not going to be in there
they're never going to allow them
because they wouldn't be good for tv
ratings
so what is what is the solution that
makes sense for all involved here
well i think there's a tweak that has to
be done in the regular season
so the committee has more data
to make determinations obviously that
was not possible this year with kovid
but i think we need to see more
crossover games more home and home games
and you know it's looking at the
schedules as they start to exist five
ten years down the road i think we're
going to get more of that but
i i think that's one piece of it and
then the other piece is that i think we
have to go to eight
and maybe sacrifice the uh
the uh conference championship games
uh because those games i mean we're
gonna wear muddy grabs
those are money grabs yeah those are
money grabs i love what happened in the
acc as a one-off this year
notre dame's inclusion was a great thing
but the the
the way they went to one league rather
than split divisions
the coastal has never actually gotten to
the to the finish line right it's always
been the atlantic i like
one league get rid of the conference
playoff games
and then we can maybe take that weekend
and create an 18 playoff which always
has
a group of five representative which
will give more inclusion to
the cincinnatis of the world and while
it's it's a long shot that they're going
to do well and win it
i think we all love cinderella notre
dame stay in the acc
after they should they should uh it'll
be an interesting question
how they would go about keeping some of
those relationships like with usc
and stanford and such and a big ten
rival but
but they should this has been a huge
success for them
i don't know what the dollars and cents
mean dan in terms of their nbc deal it's
all in the pot right now
but this for notre dame football is a
huge
uh boon in my mind i checked with my
college football source and i said notre
dame loses
how much can they lose by and then drop
out of the final four
and my source said if it's an a
m loss to alabama margin that was 52 to
24.
could you see a scenario where clemson
blows out notre dame
any chance that notre dame falls out of
the top four
it would have to be a significant
blowout
i don't know that it has to be the ohio
state wisconsin blowout 59 nothing
that we saw in 2014 but it would have to
be a significant blowout and given the
way notre dame has played
defensively i can't imagine that
happening
i i think short of anything just
monumental
the irish are in what else intrigues you
about this weekend
that we should keep an eye on oh i think
uh
you know the florida game you know the
fact that florida only fell
one spot uh why is the loss why is that
shocking shocking but i think they were
just coming well
they're trying to keep them ahead of
georgia they beat georgia but then the
question is why is georgia there right
two losses there are teams
like you mentioned usc before we came
back from the break now listen the
trojans have in terms of game control
it's their own fault they have not
looked dominant it's i can understand
where the committee's coming from
but that's a brand that's won 11
national championships
that's a brand that's sitting there uh
you know it would move the needle in
terms of television sets and yet they're
getting absolutely no
consideration but if the brand had
competed for
a national title in the last three or
four years i think usc would get
far more love and they would be higher
in the rankings
because we would go hey you know what
last year they went to the final four
the previous year whatever it is usc has
not been relevant
in a while and that's why they don't get
the benefit of
the eye test nor has the pac-12 this is
good they have been to the college
football playoff two years
in seven tries and that uh is just where
it sits
but that's why we have to expand the
playoff because that will tip the scales
back a
little bit more evenly for recruiting
purposes
it won't change that clemson ohio state
and alabama are still winning the titles
but it will change where all those
recruits are going if there are more
spots to fill
to get to the uh to get to the promised
land of the college football playoff
is auburn a good job auburn is a great
job
from a money standpoint i mean holy [ __ ]
just asking
gus is going to get 10.8 here in the
next 20 days you know uh that's that's a
good deal
and have ten more eight ten eight more
coming why not keep him
like if i'm gonna if i have to pay you
with that kind of money
i i'm gonna keep you i mean it's like a
divorce
you know is it is it is it cheaper to
just
get married you live on that side of the
house
exactly yeah this makes no sense uh
the only guy out there that i believe
would make sense is hugh freeze
and obviously they're a little bit
concerned you know that i guess the the
the people inside the program are
worried he might bring more
uh review from the ncaa
heck they hired bruce pearl they hired
bruce pearl
i mean he was he was in ncaa purgatory
and they hired him and it worked out
they went to a final four
to me hugh freeze is the answer because
both gus malzon and nick saban tried to
hire
hugh freeze to be their coordinator they
know what kind of coach he is
usually when the ncaa ncaa's looking at
you you've done well
they just questioned why you've done
well so maybe that
would be uh a positive for for auburn
amen and i think it's also a story this
year as to where is the ncaa
i i've not seen them uh be part of this
they didn't have much in the way of
answers for eligibility they didn't have
much in the way of answers
for uh what should be the protocol they
left everything up to the
individual conferences and commissioners
and uh it's been a
it's been a very weird year for that
entity in indianapolis no they're kaiser
sose
we don't know who they are perfect like
that is perfect we have no idea we know
they're there
but we don't know what they look like um
i saw this i don't know if it was a
report to be fair to it
urban meyer ucla
no way well i know i thought of all
people
knowing what you went through no way and
their
lack of commitment to their football
program urban
would would not do well at ucla well
now they do now have a buckeye as their
athletic director oh i know
martin jarman is there and they just uh
signed a
huge deal that people aren't realizing
is a huge deal with that jordan brand
the nike thing that's going now at ucla
got out from under armour
and now have the uh the nike brand uh
and
and the jordan brand along with it so
that is a monster deal for ucla but
urban no way
i think urban's is either done
comfortable with fox
or if brian kelly takes an nfl job
that would be where he would go notre
dame
well he passed on notre dame long long
time ago and i think he wants a do-over
that's just my gut i haven't talked to
urban i don't know but uh i'm throwing
that out there just because i think it's
sexy
wow i like that one better than the ucla
rumor
uh before i let you go we're talking to
rick newheisel cbs college football
analyst
uh you normally provide us with a song
whenever you oh yes i do
i don't know the holidays oh you got the
guitar
the axe is nearby oh okay it's just a
little
something you know okay what's the topic
well it's christmas
oh and we're trying to marry it a little
bit with uh what's going on in college
okay here we go here's uh rick new
heisen you know mick
lovin and paulie and
seton and fritzi all of the others
are out getting blitzed but do you
recall the most famous
reindeer of all
rudolph the covid reindeer
wasn't feeling quite himself
and when the doctor saw him
asked if he'd been near the elves
all of the other reindeer
now we're being contact traced
if they had been with rudolph
into quarantine they'd be placed
santa of course was quite concerned
christmas might be a bust
so he asked the cfp
that committee of 13 learned individuals
to get opinions he could trust
santa now felt much better
losing christmas isn't really a shame
heck he could still be santa
without even playing a game
uh it's not quite
born in the sec which
just pointing out that you still the the
great brands
are still the great brands they are
that's all that's it they they are
uh he's got a better brand than santa
now by the way
by the way your set is off awesome that
chestnut's
roasting on the open fire behind you is
that bobby knight roasting on the open
fire behind
bobby knight's behind me this is the lou
holtz doll
that was at arkansas you need to get the
uh medal of freedom
on on there for lou i i think they went
on probation soon after that was uh
that was what what a nice thing here
uh what a nice thing yeah thanks for uh
thanks for joining us as always it's
great talking
always a pleasure happy holidays yeah
and
let's finish the season congratulations
to everybody who got a college season
in this has been phenomenal to enjoy
he's rick newheisel cbs sports college
football analyst